think social media in general is all  about perception yeah that perception is  king So people do things to paint a  certain perception of themselves but  that may not necessarily be a reality of  the situation I think when I was when I  was studying a decision in consumer  science they call those a public sphere  and a privacy so now in this digital  world people have multiple  um realities that they can kind of  create for themselves right so there's  there's the digital reality it's like an  avatar it's like an avatar exactly that  so there's a digit reality is that  there's the real world reality right the  digital reality is where you you get the  people on like games like second life  where they've just create this this  fantasy of who they are and what they're  aspiring to be and to some degree they  think that's them and then you meet them  in the real world and it's just it's  nothing like it so the energy in the  vibe is all different